what was unarguably the most talked
about game from the fideo world rappin
in blitz chess championship in Moskva 20
19 might actually be one of the only
games you remember from the event now
more than four months ago the Iranian
alia resident firoozeh faced off against
the norwegian world chess champion of
magnus carlsen and what was a a game
that everyone was talking about not just
for the amazing chess that was on the
board but ultimately the appeal as you
see right here that ollie Rosa firoozeh
made later on we covered it in the news
report and maybe you haven't actually
seen live what it was that Magnus
Carlsen did at the board that that had
ali reza feeling justified in making
this appeal we're gonna point that out
to you of course when it happens on the
board and as Magnus Carlsen usually does
arrive arrive a little bit late to his
games likes to keep his opponents in
suspense ali reza gets gets buckled up
to to do his thing along with i believe
you young either in the background
versus Vladimir Kramnik and then
Vladislav Artemia facing off against yan
Christophe Duda
but with Magnus Carlsen coming to the
board and the nerves now building for
all of us althought with the young
firoozeh we see them shake hands Magnus
comes to the side and signs in for yet
another day's work as he often does just
doing his thing as the World Chess
Champion a day that ultimately crowned
him the world blitz champion but as
Magnus takes a seat we've got a few more
seconds I'm gonna preview for you what
we're gonna talk about as far as the
chess moments in the couple extra
minutes we have afterwards our cameraman
on site did such an amazing job getting
us extra footage when the controversy
started to be discussed but the moves
I'm gonna highlight for you that we
won't have as much time to do in real
fashion are Magnus Carlson's interesting
novelty idea Bishop h6 instead of the
previous a 5 from Fabiano Caruana
we're gonna talk about ollie Reza's
enterprising response to that and at
some point we're gonna jump ahead and
show that perhaps at firoozeh had played
instead queen c1 but the move 19 Bishop
takes e6 he might have actually been
winning and we may never have had any
controversy of course that could also be
said for the fact that Magnus Carlsen
instead of playing Knight takes III
keeping the bishop pair could have
played Bishop takes c3 and also gone on
to win I'm gonna show you all of those
moments and more and I'm gonna highlight
the fact that I think when Magnus played
the move King
b5 he already smelled potential blood in
the water and thought he might have a
chance to flag his young opponent so all
of that is to come in this video but for
now we jump out to a roy lopez main line
variation nothing fancy to it the move
d6 played gives firoozeh a little bit of
a pause but not much of course it is
still pretty common theory white castles
black plays Bishop to d7 and after C 3
we get g6 this is the move that really
defines this kind of closed structure
black's taking the extra time to get
developed and it's a little bit slow but
ultimately strategically perhaps he was
hoping to to help maneuver his young
opponent in the middle game fruga has
already played the move h3 and after
Knight f6 brings the bishop back to c2
both sides know what they're doing at
this point so nothing nothing too
serious to talk about castles and rook
to e1 Magnus Carlsen goes for his
vintage grab a piece and twiddle it
while I'm pretending that I don't know
what to do here of course I know the
theory I'm gonna play the move rook to
e8 and Perugia gonna get pause before
thinking about his his very natural
route Lopes approach of course the
knight coming to d2 ultimately has plans
to go as well to f1 and g3 as you do in
many spanish games Queen to e7 played by
Magnus Carlsen not necessarily played
with the intention of actually opening
up the files in these particular
structures because the Brooke honey one
will win the battery battle as Fujiya
has already played Knight of one but now
with C Queen of fate the intention of
Magnus Carlson's plan as I said Queen e7
was not played to open the file but to
go for a novelty idea where the bishop
was gonna come to h6 and try to trade
itself off for the white dark square
bishop this is an idea that hasn't
really been tried before and as I said
quickly in the preview the move a5 was
played by Fabiano Caruana in a big event
on our own server actually chess calm
but Carlsen plays the move Bishop h6 he
wants to get the dark square Bishop soph
the board positionally and makes a lot
of sense because this structure often
remains closed that bishop can be a very
dubious piece so this interesting idea
unfortunately for Carlsen is not met
with favor
Perugia says you know what I agree with
you getting rid of that Bishop will be
an improvement for you given the dark
square close structure so I'm gonna put
my night on g5 and deny you that
opportunity this is the first moment in
that really gives either player a true
think here we see Magnus grab the piece
to fiddle that I think this time
actually does have him trying to go into
his thought process of how do I want to
approach the surprising move the move on
Knight to g5 not only denies the dark
square bishop trade but also opens up
Queen to f3 to hit a now undefended
piece this is a key point to highlight
now because I'm gonna come back to it
later on it may indeed have been the key
tactic that perugia himself
underestimated as a potential
opportunity in his position but Carlsen
is stuck because the whole maneuver of
Queen f8 Bishop h6 was designed to this
for this trade to happen and with that
not being an option it's unclear whether
those pieces are ideally placed natural
moves like bringing the rooks over in
these positions can be very dangerous to
the coming threats because of that
Carlsen as you saw just played the move
Knight to d8 an exclamation point move
given by Grandmaster dejan boy cough
over in the chest calm news report
because it over protects f7 and is
already met already meaning if you
willed the move Bishop b3 with an okay
defensive setup however after the move
Knight to e6 blocking the attack of the
f7 pawn and offering more trades over
here trying to force his diagonal open
is is Magnus faroush is still stubborn
doesn't want to trade Dark Lord bishops
plays h4 to reinforce his night on g5
rather than settle on a trade or a
retreating move that will give Magnus
his goal rook to d8 now played as I said
the natural pannu maneuvers make a
little more sense with the pieces in
play Bishop to e3 to reinforce the
center the move Bishop to g7
Carlsen finally realizes he no longer
has any real chances probably of getting
this knight to blink so why keep the
bishop staring there note that trading
would never be something in the favor
because where does this knight go if it
comes to h5 we simply trade and went
upon and of course trading with the
knight would have only allowed a fork of
these two pieces so just to point out
the obvious and why Bishop g7 was played
and why after h5 perugia was already
kind of feeling the love of his position
Carlsen brings the bishop back to h6 and
this is the moment as I highlighted
earlier where Perugia could have struck
gold instead of the move Queen to c1
which he's about to play the move
Bishop takes East six was a brilliant
one after Bishop takes Queen of three
blacks pieces are actually overloaded if
you defend the night with the Queen I
take here and your Bishop has been left
behind by the Queen if you move the
knight to safety I trap your Bishop if
you take obviously this has devastating
consequences in terms of opening the
black King which makes me realize that
probably if the capture was made black
would have had to have taken with the
pawn and after D takes D takes and just
about any Queen move to get her off of
the file Black is positionally in a
terrible spot with these horrible
horrible
apparently I'm tongue twisted double D
pawns so I was surprised that a lot of
people didn't point that out and instead
after Queen to c1 it was thought that
well maybe maybe this is the right
approach from Perugia but indeed Bishop
takes East six having analyzed it with
the engine was a chance for a win after
the move Knight to g4 was played we've
already seen the trade on e6 occur and F
takes c6 Perugia going into a bit of a
think before playing rook f1 now if I'm
highlighting the Perugia could have
avoided the later controversy if he had
found Bishop takes a six it's only fair
to also highlight the Magnus Carlsen
could avoided the controversy if he
hadn't played the move Knight takes c3
which was bad Bishop takes c3 I'm gonna
analyze it real quick because after F
takes Queen h6 a brilliant inchworm
Queen to g5 followed by Queen h4 would
have actually led to a devastating
attack against Perugia and I think the
world champion would have made quick
work of his young sixteen-year-old
opponent unfortunately for Magnus he
actually was too biased to the bishop
pair here and wanted to keep that Bishop
on the board so as we've already seen he
traded with the knight and after the
move Queen to e7 and the trade on g6
which has already occurred we are now
caught up to the live position where
Queen to d2 was met with e takes d4 C
takes d4 is played and it's
understandable why Magnus might have
preferred this position he does have the
bishop here you're looking at dark
square pressure and a potentially weak
King on the dark squares and regardless
of the fact that those who know the game
well you might already know that
firoozeh was eventually the one pushing
for a win Carlson is better here and
King g7 unfortunately the slow approach
misses his chance to press Queen g5 with
the double attack on the dark squares
followed by bringing every piece to be
traded on the F file actually would have
greatly overwhelmed white and
might have actually been another chance
for carlson to be the the clear victor
instead of the controversial victor that
we saw later on but we continue here
with trades in Brooke f8 before Queen to
c3 found by firoozeh which is a bit of a
shot there in the dark you can see
Magnus has kind of had not often
something he says body language usually
something he wears on his chest and that
the piece fiddled there I don't think
he'd saw this idea and I think he he
gets a little bit frustrated by the fact
that it's clearly a double attack
against the king and the pawn on c7 he
settles on c6 which makes sense and at
this point I think black was still the
one potentially a little bit better but
after the move about to be played by
firoozeh which is Knight f1 I think here
is where Carlsen overestimates the
potential pressure of the Queen when he
settles on the move e5 you're about to
see one of the main points is that white
is never really threatening to open this
up when doing so would actually
eventually open up dark squares for this
bishop and I think would lead to a
position that's better for black so e5
as the computer suggests was actually a
small mistake and it's exactly the
blunder that after the trade and the
move Queen to c4 you're about to see
that led to these light square problems
suddenly jay-z's got 99 of them and
Magnus is in trouble so whether I 5 was
a horrible blunder or really it's just
this move Queen f6 instead of Queen g7
as danboy cough correctly analyzed the
bottom line is either way he he's
suddenly in huge trouble here after the
move Queen before check we see Carlsen
get frustrated before playing c5 with
the loud sort of clock slam we are
moments away from what ultimately was
the controversial moment after the check
here and the Queen captures the pawn it
was this moment right here and the words
whispered by Magnus that ultimately led
to the controversy and the challenge
that we forced out in the beginning the
video more on that later the Queen trade
and we see all the blunders have led to
an end game where only white can be
winning Carlsen correctly transitions
into an obstacle bishop affair where you
often have your best drawing chances but
the moves here are now gonna come pretty
fast and furious so I'm gonna do my best
to keep up providing little bits of
insights as I can stick around because
all the things we've already touched on
that we didn't get to I promise to
deliver with analysis on those moments
when this game concludes well we do see
here though is pretty good
Niq from the youngster he balances both
sides of the board even the move king f2
that ultimately comes back this way
shows that he's he's trying to create
threats of past pawns and King entry
everywhere the King comes up we play G
for that pawn being knocked over might
be a little bit of a foreshadowing of
something to come both in terms of the
fact that it was knocked over and the
politeness in which ferocious showed to
reset the pawn up before hitting the
clock again more on that later King to
g6 shows that Carlsen is in big trouble
the b-pawn combine with the king
targeting things over here ultimately
leads to some bad news and again here we
see the pond being slipped from what I
believe was a very nervous ferocious
hands understandably so but right here
right now the move Bishop d2 pointed out
as a blunder by some I think was
actually Carlson really calling the kids
Bluff Purusha needed to find king f7
again I'm gonna show that later
instead he doesn't and takes the bait
that the pawn was actually attacked but
now in the time scramble we're gonna see
that Carlsen block hating the dark
squares ends up confusing the youngster
just enough where you wouldn't call it
now that he's about to lose on time but
if you look at the body language of the
players and how much more time just a
second extra that he's taking on every
move is really gonna up and there it is
it's leading to the nerves that comes
out and it for King g4 we see the drama
is real the table is slammed and the
arbiter has set up the pieces way for it
in a draw according to the dgt board and
we see Magnus Carlsen is actually not
happy about that now as we as we see
them debating this I'm gonna provide a
little bit of insight into what you see
on the board the Kings being put on
these two squares and why the
controversial debates already started
getting getting crazy the Kings being
there represents a draw to the dgt board
that's what the arbiter was claiming
Magnus knows his rules and his immediate
sort of frustration with that ruling we
can see is what led me to believe that
he already knew he had a chance to flag
Ally Reza as far back as perhaps this
move I'm gonna show it right now the
move King takes b5 rather than trying to
maybe sit tight on the blockade I think
he knew that was some tough questions
the kid might use more time than he
the next few moves yes you could argue
that Bishop to c3 is the best block
heating move but white is still winning
with best play so I actually think this
move Bishop to d2 again calling the kids
Bluff making him think his pawn is
hanging when actually after Bishop d2
the move king of seven would be winning
on the spot sacrificing the bishop and
going into a winning King and pawn
ending and again a lot of this is
speculation I admit I've now watched
this 17 minute video probably many more
times the knight then I should have
given that you know I'm supposed to be
getting paid to do other things but hey
you know what we're here and I actually
think that Carlson knew very well that
if this game lit led to a loss on time
for Borussia that he wins in that call
just because there's opposite code
bishops on the board and no other mating
material does not mean that according to
the fidei bylaws black isn't winning in
fact he's right but you'll find out
later on in the news report or what you
did find out later on in the news report
was that the feed a ruling says as long
as there's in theory a possible
checkmate then the game can be deemed a
win despite not having what is
considered theoretical mating material
so in the end with much time we see
firoozeh is getting that explained to
him right now he actually he actually
did make the right call meaning the
arbiter as I'm saying with more time
eventually makes the right call for
jokes well it kind of laughs it off now
but later we know he was super
frustrated now what exactly was the
chess moment the deeply frustrated
firoozeh that moment we saw earlier at
about the 10 minute and 31 second mark
where Magnus Carlsen I don't think was
whispering sweet nothings to firoozeh
in terms of his frustration with the
position but actually maybe letting his
his feelings show about what he knew was
happening after the move queen of six
was played and as I highlighted 'if i
was really maybe the blunder the blunder
is start to that plan it was this
combination that picks up the b7 pawn
and ultimately the c5 pawn this moment
that had Magnus very frustrated and and
saying whatever it was he did that was
later of course appealed to and
overruled as if it is the case that your
opponent is distracting you which is
what Furuta tried to claim he should
made that claim in the moment how the
arbiters would have ruled no one really
knows people almost never make claims in
the moment despite their opponent
cursing under their breath because
frankly magnus carlsen is a competitor
and he was frustrated and it's
understandable that he may have he may
have been a little bit upset whether
it's right to say something and say it
out loud is another case but either way
if you're frustrated about something
your opponent is doing you have to claim
it in the moment which of course
firoozeh did not now what I was saying
about what I think magnus carlsen did
back here rather than selling on the
passive blockade but starting to sense
his young opponents nerves playing the
aggressive King takes b5 and then the
aggressive maneuver of the bishop to d2
again looking at it knowing that there
was an opportunity to get your opponent
to try to overthink it I think Carlson
did just that capitalize on the fact
that Perugia was unable to find King f7
with no time on his clock and knew what
he was doing to get the victory now I
want to show you some of the some of the
actual chess here as a lot was being
debated in this particular position with
about a minute to go here in this
particular position I want to show that
peruggia's best chance at a win was
actually right here instead of the move
came to g4 but with the move g6 the
point is the threat of g7 would force
Bishop to e5 and now King h6 followed by
a sacrifice of the e pawn would have
actually led to a win what's funny to
know is that the final position is
actually a draw now if Carlson has the
right technique the reason is that if
you ever play g6 now the bishop can come
back to h6 and hold all the dark squares
and there's no way in and if you try to
bring the King in the point is that the
bishop can actually I'm going to show
this way if you try to bring the King in
either way King if I work in from the
bishop can go to the diagonal just in
time and if you ever push the bishop
goes here and if you ever try to lead
with the King the bishop goes back to d2
so in the final position Magnus Carlsen
had actually held a draw or and or
depending on how you want to see it all
the arrests of Perugia had missed a win
but regardless of that the position has
claimed a win for Magnus Carlsen because
of the loss on
time now again that all happened because
of perugia doing the right thing I want
to point that out whenever you make a
move the knocks down a piece you should
set it up before you hit the clock
however as many players who played over
the board blitz will attest to that's
not always the thing that's done many
times people make move they knock pieces
over and then they set them up on their
opponents clock highlighting the
firoozeh did the right thing and that
setting up this King before hitting the
clock lost in the game only makes this
defeat that much more of a nightmare I
guess you will for firoozeh and perhaps
that much more of a reason why he will
remember this battle in future blitz
blitz Affairs versus Magnus Carlsen so
hope you enjoyed this video again we
tried to highlight all the different
crazy critical chests that happened as
well as the controversy give us a light
give us a share and let us know if we
brought you any new insights into a game
that surely you had already seen but now
maybe you have a little bit more
knowledge of what exactly was the moment
that that led to the controversial
appeal from Perugia as well as what the
chest was telling us on the board
throughout that time scramble so thanks
for tuning in and more more from the
chest comm blitz archives coming your
way soon you can click on either of the
videos in front of you if you're really
into these types of videos and we'll see
you around on chest comm